this is Arthur Kuma with K State what
player do you model your game after man
really Paul George Paul George is nice
feel like he inspired a generation he
don't miss like that who is your
favorite rapper at the moment probably
going to what app do you use the most
Teamworks I always got to stay up on our
schedule what is your favorite pair of
sneakers in your closet probably my
black cat fors I like to keep it simple
if you could have a sports related
superpower what would it be probably
jump super high like just be able to
jump above the backboard what is your
first March Madness memory I actually
played my brother we beat him in the
very first game and that was a crazy
memory last but not least if you were
going to try to get someone out in horse
what would your shot be this one right
here oh Karine that's going to get him
for sure